طابع مساؤكم نحييكم وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء هذه عناوينها
في اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه
تعيد دمشق الى مقعدها مع مطالب محدده
وقرار عوده العلاقات مع الاعضاء السيادي
فردي
استمرار للشبكات في الخرطوم ومساعدات
انسانيه سعوديه للشعب السوداني بقيمه 100
مليون دولار
الوضع الاقتصادي يبعد اصوات الشباب عن
اردوغان وغريمه يحاول التقرب منهم
تكنولوجيا
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه قلقه من الضغوط
والتوقعات الغربيه العاليه حول الهجوم
المضاد
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء تبنى وزراء
الخارجيه العرب قرارا باستعاده سوريا
لمقعدها بالجامعه بعدما يزيد على عشر
سنوات من تعليق عضويتها القرار جرى اتخاذه
خلال اجتماع مغلق لوزراء الخارجيه وذلك في
مقر جامعه الدول العربيه بالقاهره
وستستانف مشاركه سوريا في اجتماعات مجلس
الجامعه اعتبارا من اليوم وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري اكد ان مراحل الازمه
السوريه اثبتت انه لا يوجد حل عسكري لها
وانه لا يوجد غالب او مغلوب في الصراع
[موسيقى]
اتخذت الدول العربيه قرارا باستئناف
مشاركه وفد الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في
اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه وجميع
المنظمات والاجهزه التابعه لها اعتبارا من
اليوم 7 مايو 2023
اكرر مجددا على ضروره وفاء كل من الحكومه
السوريه والقوه الوطنيه والمكونات السوريه
والمجتمع الدولي والدول المعنيه بالازمه
بالتزاماتها كل اتجاه الاخر
من جهته الامين العام للجامعه العربيه
احمد ابو الغيط قال ان قرار اعاده سوريا
للجامعه العربيه لا يعني اعاده الدول
العربيه لعلاقاتها مع سوريا مشيرا الى ان
هذا قرار سيادي تتخذه كل دوله
عوده سوريا الى شغل المقعد
هي بدايه حركه وليست نهايه مطاف بمعنى انه
مسار التسويه للازمه السوريه هتاخذ مرحله
من الاجراءات والتدرج فيها ومهمه هذه
اللجنه هي متابعه هذه
الاجراءات ايضا هي ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سياجي لكل دوله على حده
نحن نتحدث في هذا القرار عن
شغل المقعد وتشكيل اللجنه للتواصل مع
الحكم في سوريا
من جهه وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه قالت ان
واشنطن تتفهم سعي الشركاء للتواصل المباشر
مع رئيس السوري بشار الاسد لمزيد من الضغط
لحل الازمه السوريه اضافت الخارجيه
الامريكيه انها تشكك برغبه بشار الاسد بحل
الازمه في سوريا لكنها تتفق مع الشركاء
العرب حول الاهداف النهائيه وقالت انها
تعتقد انه من المبكر عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه
نذهب مباشره عبر الهاتف من القاهره السفير
حسام زكيله من العام المساعد للدول جامعه
الدول العربيه سعاده السفير مرحبا بكم
معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء هل يمكن القول
بان الصفحه السابقه طويت مع دمشق هل نحن
امام صفحه
ينتظر تطبيقها
الواضح انه الدول العربيه اليوم اخذت
قرارا
بان تبدا العلاقه
مع سوريا مرحله جديده تختلف شكلا وربما
ايضا موضوع عن المرحله التي سبقت والتي
كانت مدتها حوالي 12 عام
وبطبيعه الحال كل مرحله لها
لها يعني
خصائصها ولها عناصرها ولها الاسس التي
تقوم عليها الوضع في 12 عام كان مرتبط
بالاوضاع الميدانيه في سوريا الان هناك
وضع جديد تطلب موقفا جديدا والدول الان
وصلت الى خلاصه مفادها ان
استعاده سوريا الى الجماعه وعدد سوريا الى
القطط الجامعه هو ربما افضل
للمصلحه السوريه والعربيه معا سعاده
السفير وبالتالي نعم مفهوم بانه خطوه
مقابل خطوه لكن هل من سقف زمني لتطبيق
الشروط وبالتالي ايضا من يضع اليه
المراقبه لتطبيق هذه الشروط
يعني شوفي حضرتك المسائل الخاصه باطار
زمني واليه مراقبه هي مسائل يعني ممكن
انها تنطبق على تواجد على الارض في نزاعات
من نوع اخر ولكن نحن هنا بصدد موضوع اساسا
الان اصبح موضوعا سياسيا وفي بعض الامور
التي تحدثت فيها دول يعني معنيه حتى اكثر
من غيرها لانها دول جوار مباشر مع سوريا
ولديها مصالح مشتركه
الكل يريد ان يحقق مصلحه في هذا الامر
والكل يعتقد انه المصلحه تبدا بمصلحه يعني
سوريا باعتبارها يعني دوله جزء من النظام
العربي واعاده الان الى الجماعه العربيه
الدول
والتي تاثرت تاثرا كبيرا
بالوضع الذي كان قائما على مدار العقد
الماضي فبالتالي
مساله الاطار الزمني هنا لم لم تكن مطروحه
وبالتالي هي ليست منعكسه في القرار الذي
وزعناه على الاعلام وموجود امام
المحاضراتكم سعاده السفير اليوم وقد عادت
سوريا لمقعدها الى جامعه الدول العربيه
يعني حكما بان رئيس السوري بشار الاسد
سيحضر القمم العربيه المقبله
نعم ستوجه له الدعوه لانه القرار يعتبر
انه العوده من تاريخ اليوم وبالتالي ستوجه
له الدعوه وتوجه
لسوريا الدعوه على مستويات
اخرى الوزاريه وبيروف فبالتالي طبيعي انه
اذا
راى
الرئيس السوري ان يحضر فهو سوف يحضر وهذا
امر طبعا يعني قرار لكل دوله ولكل رئيس
دوله
سعاده السفير لمين العام للجامعه العربيه
احمد ابو الغيط يقول بين قرار اعاده سوريا
للجامعه العربيه لا يعني اعاده الدول
العربيه لعلاقاتها مع سوريا وانه قرار
سيادي هل حضور الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
ان تم فعلا في القمه العربيه المقبله
سيكسر الجليد مع هذه الدول
بطبيعه الحال هناك
تحقق
وزاد بشكل كبير من بعد
يعني ماساه الزلزال التي حدثت في مطلع شهر
فبراير ونتج عن ذلك عدد من اللقاءات
والزيارات مع عدد من الدول
ومن الممكن جدا ان نرى مزيدا من
التطبيع الثنائي لكن بس للتوضيح واجابه
الامين العام كان الهدف منها تبيان ان
هناك فصل ما بين المسارات الثنائيه الخاصه
بكل دوله مع سوريا والمسار المتعدد اليوم
المسار المتعدد يعني في اطار النظام
العربي الكل يعني توافق على فكره انه
العوده لسوريا لكي تشغل المقعد هو افضل من
غيابها عن المقعد في كل الفتره السابقه
سعاده السفير ملف اللاجئين احد المعضلات
الرئيسيه وكان دائما الحديث بانه يجب
الحوار اقله فيما يتعلق لحلحله ملف
الانساني وخصوصا اللاجئين هل حصلتم على
ضمانات وهل ستقدم سوريا ضمانات لعوده امنه
للاجئين وحتى في المناطق التي حصل فيها
تغيير ديموغرافي بحكم الحرب في سوريا
شوفي حضرتك هذا الملف يعني واضح انه ملف
يحظى باهتمام كبير جدا بالذات من جانب
الدول الاكثر استقبالا للاجئين ونعني بها
هنا لبنان والاردن
والعراق ايضا ولكن لبنان والاردن بشكل
كبير لانه تاثير مباشر على الاوضاع
المعيشيه وفي تاثر بكل الحاله الاقتصاديه
فطبيعي انه هذا الملف فهو ملف في غايه
الاهميه بالنسبه للكثيرين وايضا بالنسبه
التصور بالنسبه للسوريين نفسهم يعني الشعب
والمدنيين الذين
يرغب منهم من يرغب في ان يعود وكما تنفصل
الاتفاقيات الدوليه واتفاقيات اللاجئين
على العوده الطوعيه
للاجئين والكريم ايضا فطبعا هذا المسار
واضح انه ويكون
مسار حديث
واحاديث مطوله
مع الجانب السوري وفهمنا من كل
الاخوه ممثله دول الذين شاركوا في اجتماع
عمان واجتماع جده من قبله انه هذا الملف
قضيه باهتمام كبير مع ملفات اخرى طبعا
ولكن
هذا الملف كان يعني يشكل اهميه خاصه
ونعتقد انه اللجنه التي تم تشكيلها سوف
تولي له الاهميه التي يستحقها
نشكركم جزيل الشكر من القاهره السفير حسام
زكي من
العمل في ذات السياق قال الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط ان
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد من حقه المشاركه
في اجتماع القمه المقبل للجامعه العربيه
اذا راغب في ذلك سوريا
ابتداء من مساء اليوم هي عدوه كامل
العضويه بالجامعه العربيه ومن صباح غد لهم
الحق في شغل اي مقعد يشاركون فيه عندما
توجه الدعوه من قبل الدوله الضيافه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واذا ما رغب ان
يشارك فسوف يشارك
[موسيقى]
سنه كانت كافيه لعوده سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه
يا الله الحكايه بدات مع اندلاع اعمال
العنف في البلاد عام 2011 في الاجتماع
الشهير لوزراء الخارجيه العرب في القاهره
تم اقرار تعليق عضويه سوريا في الجامعه
لحين التزام الحكومه السوريه بتنفيذ بنود
المبادره العربيه تعليق مشاركه وفد حكومه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماع
جامعه مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه القرار
حينها طالب الدول العربيه بسحب سفرائها من
دمشق لكنه اعتبر ذلك امرا سياديا لكل دوله
وزراء الخارجيه العرب اتفقوا ايضا وقتئذ
على توقيع عقوبات اقتصاديه وسياسيه على
الحكومه السوريه مندوب سوريا لدى الجامعه
وصفاحينها القرار بغير القانوني والمخالف
اهلا بكم من جديد في التاسعه هذا المساء
وجه العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
وجهها مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه بتقديم
مساعدات انسانيه متنوعه بقيمه 100 مليون
دولار لصالح الشعب السوداني كما وجه الملك
سلمان والامير محمد بن سلمان بتنظيم حمله
شعبيه عبر منصه ساهم وذلك لتخفيف اثار
الاوضاع التي يمر بها الشعب السوداني
حاليا
[موسيقى]
اذا محادثات جاريه على جهه وعلى الجهه
الاخرى دوي انفجارات ورصاص متناثر دون
هواده فالمعارك بين طرفين نزاع في السودان
على اشدها وتحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم رغم
ارسال الطرفين وفودا الى السعوديه لاجراء
محادثات حول هدنه جديده الرياض واشنطن حتى
كلا الطرفين على استشعار مسؤولياتهما
الشعب السوداني والانخراط الجاد في هذه
المحادثات ورسم خريطه طريق للمباحثات لوقف
العمليات العسكريه وبالتالي تجنب مفاقمه
الشعب السوداني من قطاع المياه والكهرباء
ونقص مخزون الطعام وضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه للمناطق المتضرره وكان بيان
مشترك للولايات المتحده والسعوديه اعلن عن
عقد ممثلين عن الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في محادثات مشتركه في جده يوم
السبت بهدف بحث سبل انهاء الاقتتال
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه المشتركه
الشاد بها كل من قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقله كما لقي الترحيبا اقليميا
ودوليا النصر
نذهب الان الى لندن ومعلم هناك عمار حموده
القيادي في التجمع الاتحادي وناطق رسمي
لقوى الحريه والتغيير في المجلس المركزي
بالخارج مرحبا بكم معنا سيد عمار اليوم
تقييمكم الى اين وصلت الامور خصوصا ان
الانظار كلها متجهه الى جده
مرحب بك وبضيوفك وبمشاهديك
بدايه نترحم على الشهداء وعاجل الشفاء
للجرحى الاوضاع من كافه المناحي يعني
ميدانيا ما يزال القصف مستمر خرق الهدنه
موجود
انسانيا المعاناه تتفاقم ولكن الجيد انه
سياسيا هناك بوارق امل في بدء المفاوضات
في تسميه المفاوضين في الاجتماع في بدايه
العمليه هنا اقوى الحريه والتغيير تشكر
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده ومن خلفهم الرباعيه والثلاثيه
وكافه المجتمع الدولي المعني بالعمليه
نتمنى انه تتطور الهدنه الى وقف شامل
لاطلاق النار ومن ثم اطلاق العمليه
السياسيه التفاوضيه التي يجب ان يكون فيها
مدنيون استاذ عمار متى يمكن ان تقطف ثمار
المباحثات في جده وتترجم على الارض
نحن نرى ان استمرار القتال هو الذي يمنع
اي مظاهر للتعبير السلمي لمواطنين السودان
لارائهم بصوره شعبيه ولذلك اي كل تعجيل
لاسكان صوت البنات او المدافع سريعا هو في
صالح الشعب السوداني نريد ان نصل الى وقف
الاطلاق النار لايجاد مرات امنه
لارجاع سلاسل الامداد
لامدادات المستشفيات هناك كثير من
الانتهاكات تدور على الارض من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع او قوات اخرى
وطيران يقصف
ومدفعيه تقصف من جانب
جيش او قوات الشعب المسلحه هذه الامور
كلها يجب ان تقف حفاظا على الدم السوداني
طيب سيد عمار ماذا عنكم الى اي حد يجب على
القوى السياسيه اليوم ان تلتزم الحياد
لصفاف مع اي من الطرفين خصوصا بعد
الاتهامات التي طالتكم في الحريه والتغيير
بانكم كنتم تنحزون الى طرف دون اخر في
فتره توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي
هذه مساله روج لها كثيرا اعداء الحريه
والتغيير الحريه والتغيير لها رؤيه مكتوبه
نصت على ان نصل الى جيش مهني موحد عبر
اتفاق مدروس
وموقعه عليه وعبر فتره زمنيه يتم الاتفاق
حولها ما تم ما بعد ذلك في الانزلاق لحاله
الحرب جعلت كثير من الناس يتوهمون انهم
بالصاقهم مثل هذه التهم يمكن ان يغيروا
الحقائق ولكن موقف الحريه والتغيير من
وجود جيش مهني موحد من دمج القوات ليس فقط
قوات الدعم السريع انما كافه القوات التي
تحمل السلاح في السودان هو هذا هو هدفها
الاسماء وخروج هذه المؤسسه العسكريه كامله
من الحياه السياسيه
واكاله الامر الى جهه مدنيه ومن ثم الوصول
للانتخابات هذا هو الطريق الذي انتهجته
الحريه والتغيير ولا تحتاج ان تزايد على
ذلك باكثر من انها ضمنت هذا المشروع
السياسي واستثمرت فيه كل طاقاتها السياسيه
اصولنا لهذه المرحله الان نحن خلف هذه
المبادرات
مثل المبادره السعوديه التي تترجم هذه
الاعمال الى واقع نحن الان في حاله ابتعد
الرجوع الى الخلف ولكننا نتقدم بفعل يفعله
الاصدقاء
في مرحله رجوع الى الخلف ما مصير الاتفاق
الاطاري هل نسفته المعارك تماما عدنا الى
مربع صفر ام يمكن البناء على مباحثات جده
والانطلاق خطوه اخرى
عموما في كل السياسه يعني كل سياسي حصيف
او مهمته هذا الحلول لا يمكن ان يظل في
مربع واحد ويصر على ان يبدا منه نحن نبدا
من حيث الان الان نحن لدينا مدافع تنطلق
يجب اسكاتها اولا لدينا وضع جديد فيه امور
مزريه من ناحيه انسانيه من ناحيه صحيه من
ناحيه سياسيه علينا ان نعترف بهذا الواقع
الجديد وان نصنع من ركام هذه المعارك
مستقبلا جديدا للسودانيين هذه هي المهمه
الاساسيه لاي سياسه عليه فان التعويل على
على مباحثات جده ليس فقط يعني اتكالا على
الجانب الخارجي ولكن هذه مساعدات لمساعده
السودانيين ليساعدوا انفسهم للمدنيين لكي
يثبتوا للعالم انه هم اصحاب الحق في
الحياه الكريمه في الحريات العامه في
نزوعهم الى الدوله المدنيه في جيش المهني
الموحد في كل هذه الامور ولذلك الشعب
السوداني هو الذي سيقرر الخط وات السياسيه
اللاحقه لانه هو على الارض شكرا جزيلا لك
من لندن عمار حموده القياده في التجمع
الاتحاد وناطق رسمي لقوى الحريه والتغيير
مجلس المركزي بالخارج
تجاره المنتجات الاستهلاكيه الاكثر شهره
في العالم مهدده هذا التهديد مركزه
السودان فالمشروبات الغازيه مثل كوكاكولا
الواح لتشوكليت والواحنا العلكه ومنتجات
اخرى قد تتاثر بشكل كبير بصراع السلطه
الدائره هناك وفق صحيفه وولدسي جونيل
الصمغ العربي مكون غير معروف لكنه حاسم في
هذه المنتجات حيث ينتج السودان 80% منه عن
طريق اشجار اكاسيا وغالبا ما يتم استخدام
النسخ المجفف الذي لا تعمله ورائحه كعامل
استقرار وسماكه وتتم اضافه كميات صغيره
منه لمنتجات استهلاكيه وايضا مستحضرات
تجميل هذه الازمه تتسبب بعرقله امدادات
الصمغ العربي فضلا عن ارتفاع اسعار الماده
بشكل كبير ففي وقت لم تتاثر المناطق
المنتجه لهذه الماده بالاشتباكات الا ان
نقص الوقود جعل من المستحيل عمليا نقل
الصمغ داخل السودان او تص ويره لدوله اخرى
غير ان تجارا ومستوردين للصمغ الخام اكدوا
ان العرض الفوري ليس بخطر ان لم تستمر
الحرب لمده عام طالما ان الشركات الكبرى
تحتفظ بمخزونات كبيره خارج السودان
[موسيقى]
الى تركيا حيث يخوضوا سته ملايين ناخبا
شاب تجربه الانتخابات للمره الاولى في
الرابع عشر من مايو القادم وهؤلاء من ضمن
قرابه ثلاثه عشر مليون ناخب يطلق عليهم
الجيل زد حيث يبلغ عدد الناخبين الاجمالي
62.4 مليون ناخب ومن المنتظر ان يكون لهذه
الشريحه دور كبير في الانتخابات القادمه
سواء لدعم اردوغان او منافسه لاسيما كمال
كل تشارل اوغلو
[موسيقى]
رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس الثاني عشر لتركيا
واكثر الزعماء حكما للبلاد كرئيس للوزراء
ورئيس الجمهوريه خلال عقدين من حكمه نشا
جيل كامل هو الجيل زد او جيل الالفيه الذي
لم يعرف حاكما غير اردوغان اكثر من سته
ملايين شاب سيصوتون للمره الاولى ومجمل
اعداد الجيل زد يبلغ قرابه 13 مليون ناخب
وفق علماء اجتماع فان هذا الجيل لا يرتبط
بقائد معين اي انهم غير متعصبين لاي حزب
او مجموعه او فئه بل هم جيل متقلب ومتغير
بشكل يومي قلنا
نتحدث عن جيل له توجهات متغيره ومتضاربه
في الترجيح والاختيار نظرا لذلك اذا اردنا
التعرف على توجهات هذا الجيل في
الانتخابات يجب علينا الاعتماد على اخر
الاحصاءات التي تسبق الانتخابات بايام
قليله لان هذا الجيل يغير ارائه بشكل يومي
واذا اردنا تثبيت اصواتهم بصوره اقرب ما
تكون للواقع يجب ان نعتمد دوما على
المعلومات المحدثه عند اعداد هذا التقرير
قررنا اجراء مقابلات مع الشباب في احدى
جامعات اسطنبول لان الجامعات تضم مختلف
المشاعر والاراء لذلك كان سؤال الشباب لمن
ستصوتون وما هي الاسباب التي دفعتهم
للاختيار
لست متاكدا بالضبط لكن اتصور باني ساصوت
لكمالك الجدار اوغلو لاني ارى ان الحكومه
الحاليه يجب ان تتغير
اذا نظرنا الى المسار السياسي الحالي
لتركيا واذا اردنا ان نعرف من سيحسن الوضع
الحالي فانني مازلت متردده
استطلاعات الراي تقول ان غالبيه هذا الجيل
لا يؤيد اردوغان انما يريد تغييرا في شكل
الحكم والياته بما يناسب تطلعاته لكن
الرئيس التركي لديه الكثير من الوعود
الانتخابيه لهذه الفئه ومن ضمنها تاسيس
بنك الشباب والاسره وتسهيل حصولهم على
قروض ومنح ماليه
وملايين الوظائف الجديده
فهل ينجح في استقطابهم صناديق الاقتراع في
الرابعه عشر من مايو ستجيب على هذا السؤال
تمثل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي منبرا
اساسيا من منابر الدعايه والوصول الى جيل
الشباب لذلك انشا معظم المرشحين حسابات
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ونخص بالذكر
هنا تطبيق التيك توك الذي لجا اليه مرشحون
رئاسه مؤخرا للوصول الى قلوب وعقول الشباب
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
قد اشترى في التصويت الكليتشر لاني غير
راض عن اوضاع البلد خاصه في المجال
الاقتصادي بمعزل عن المسار السياسي ارى ان
الاقتصاد بات بحاجه لتغيير الحزب الحاكم
وبراي ان افضل مرشح لذلك هو
لن اصوت لرجب طيب اردوغان باختصار لا داعي
لتجربه المجرب من جديد حاله البلد من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه واضحه ساصوت لكمال
كليتشا وصادقا لذلك توقعوا انه سيتفهم
حاله البلاد والفقراء
يعمل بجد زعيم جيد وقوي سنقف خلفه دوما
رجل صالح ولذلك ساصوت له اراه الخيار
الجيد للبلاد ساصوت لكليتش
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي ولكون حزبنا يدعم
مرشحه تحالف الامه
لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي لاني احب صلاح
الدين دملتاش واحب افكاره لا احب افكار
الاخرين
نذهب الى اسطنبول ومعنا زيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه زيدان اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه
هذا المساء يعني انطلاقا من التقرير
ومعرضناه من اراء الجيل زاد يعني يبدو انه
حتى الجيل زد يا زيدان غير متفق على مرشح
مفضل واحد على كل حال زيدان اذا ما ذهبنا
الى التطورات الميدانيه السياسيه يعني
عندما نرى هذه الحشود لتجمعات ضخمه لكل من
المرشحين المتنافسين في اسطنبول بالذات ما
دلالات ذلك مؤخرا
نعم لا شك هي المحاوله الاخيره لكلا
المرشحين لاستقطاب الفئه المتردده التي لم
تتخذ قرار لمن ستصوت لكن جدار اوغلو مرشح
المعارضه او لرجب طيب اردوغان مرشح
لائتلاف الحاكم لذلك كانت اسطنبول هي نقطه
او النقطه التي اراد منها كلا المرشحين
استعراض القوه في الشارع لاسيما اتحدث هنا
على وجه الخصوص الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي اراد الرد على استطلاعات
الراي التي كانت تعطي خصمه
افضليه في الانتخابات ولا سيما ان
المعارضه ايضا كانت تتحدث بانها ستكسب
الانتخابات وان اسطنبول قد حسمت قرارها
لصالح المعارضه وبالتالي اراد اردوغان على
وجه التحديد اكثر من منافسك الجدار اوغلو
اليوم ان يبرهن انه مازال الرجل القوي
الذي يمتلك حضور قوي في الشارع وتم اعداد
هذا الحشد الكبير جدا حقيقه بعنايه
تكتيك كبير ومختلف من قبل الاحزاب المؤيده
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وطبعا من حزب
العداله والتنميه كان هناك دعوات كبيره
خلال الايام والاسابيع الماضيه
لمؤيدي الرئيس التركي للحضور الى مطار
اتاتورك للمشاركه في هذا التحالف لكن ايضا
تحالف الامه هو تحالف كبير وفق معطيات
المعارضه نظرا الى التجمعات التي كانت
التي كانت المعارضه تنظمها في اسطنبول
يعتبر من اكبر التجمعات الانتخابيه
للمعارضه التركيه لكنه اقل بكثير من تحالف
او من التجمع الانتخابي للرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان كما قلت هي رساله قويه
وتم تم اعداد هذا التجمع بعنايه حتى تصل
الصوره بشكل يظهر الرئيس اردوغان بانه
مازال يحظى بتاييد كبير لكن ايضا كما ذكرت
الطاوله السداسيه وهي الائتلاف المع
حشدت كل امكانياتها في اسطنبول يوم امس
وكانت حصلت على تجمع واكبر تجمع تقريبا
للمعارضه في هذه الانتخابات بالعموم
المشهد طبعا هو ايضا هذه التجمعات لن
تتوقف هنا كلا المرشحين يواصلون الزيارات
الولايات الاخرى لاستكمال او للتواصل مع
الناخبين وايضا نشهد تجمعات كبيره لكن بلا
شك ليست بحجم التجمع التجمعات التجمعات
التي شهدتها مدينه اسطنبول اليوم للائتلاف
الحاكم ويوم امس الائتلاف المعارضه شكرا
جزيلا كل هذه الاضاحات من اسطنبول زيدان
زنكلو مراسل العربيه
الانتقادات الموجهه لرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان والمتمثله ببعده عن راي العام
يحاول غريبه الاول استغلالها لمصلحته
فيديوهات دعائيه عده انتشرت بكثره على
مواقع التواصل لكمال كلار اوغلو مرشح
تحالف الامه المعارض لانتخابات الرئاسه
التركيه مرتديا قميصا ابيض اللون وفي
الخلفيه مطبخ منزلها المتواضع او مكتبته
هو يخاطب اوغلو الناخبين من خلال هذه
الصور وحاولا اظهار انه يعيش حياه طبيعيه
وانه ليس سياسيا نخبويا بل يستطيع فهم
المشاكل من الناس مقاطع الفيديو هذا سعت
الى تقديم خصم اردوغان كشخصيه لطيفه شخصيه
مقبوله وكجسر لجيل سياسي جديد يختلف في كل
شيء عن اردوغان الذي غالبا ما يكون قتاليا
مستقدما رغم مواقفها المتقاربه بالسياسه
الخارجيه فيما يخص ملف اللاجئين كل شجار
استخدم كذلك مهاره الاستاذ في شرح خططي
الاقتصاديه في محاوله اخرى لمقارنه
مؤهلاتهم مؤهلات اردوغان الذي يلقي باللوم
على ارائه الاقتصاديه غير التقليديه في
مضاعفه حجم التضخم وفق ما تقول واشنطن
بوست كما حقق احد الفيديوهات اكثر من 36
مليون مشاهده ابدا فيه تطلعه للمساواه بين
المواطنين على اساس المواطنه الفيديو وصفه
البعض بمغازله جماعات توصف في الاقليات في
تركيا
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى اسطنبول لا عبر زوم الدكتور رحمه
الاقتصادي دكتور احمد اهلا بك معنا في هذه
النشره على العربيه الى اي حد يمثل الوضع
الاقتصادي التركي ملفا حاسما في
الانتخابات التركيه المقبله وعليه سيتوجه
الناخب التركي
عند
من الحكومه والمعارضه قد قدم سلسله من
الوعود باتخاذ تدابير اقتصاديه في البلاد
قبيله الانتخابات فارجوغان
قبل الانتخابات من خلال وضع خارطه في طريق
يتم من خلالها تعزيز الوضع الاقتصادي
وكذلك ايضا تحدث الخصم عن مساله
تخفيضي العجز الذي حل بالبلاد العجز
التجاري والعمل على التذليل العقبات
المتعلقه بالتضخم وكل منهما قد ركز على
كيفيه تجاوز الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تشكل
عاملا اساسيا
والامر الذي كان
في وقت من الاوقات مساله ذات نقاط القوه
لاردوغان عندما ارتقى بالاقتصاد في تركيا
وهناك اكثر من
85% في المئه من الناس يرون بان
التحولا كبيرا قد طرا على اسعار البضائع
بسبب تضخم مما
بدد من قدرتهم وقوتها مش يره الشرائيه
هناك ايضا
تطلعات من خلال رسم سياسه الحكوميه
مستقبليه
للسيد كمال كلتشارد الذي قال من خلالها
بانه سوف يعمل على معالجه كل اوجه القصور
التي شابت الوضع الاقتصادي اما اردوغان
فهو ما دال ما زال
يتحدث بامجاد الماضي وما حققه من انجازات
اقتصاديه في فتره
ذهبيه من البلاد
وما حققه من انجازات في البنى التحتيه
والشوارع
ومشابه ذلك بالاضافه الى تامين
زيوت التدفئه والغاز الى عدد كبيره من
المنازل والمناطق الريفيه وكذلك ايضا
كبير من الموارد النفطيه في البلاد هذه
الاوقات قد تكون مثيره للاهتمام بالنسبه
للمرشحين لان كل منهم سوف
يطرحوا
بطرق تعامله مع ملفات المختلفه بما في ذلك
الوضع
ما في ذلك الوضع العسكري واخر التطورات
التي حدثت من خلال المحادثه اردوغان مع
نظيره الروسي
وكذلك وجود بعض الشركات العسكريه التي
لديها روابط مشتركه في التعاون العسكري
اما سياسه اردوغان فهي تعتمد على دعم غير
مباشر لبعض
ترجمه لا
تجوز لا
ريكا بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه الحكمه
الامريكيه تقول بانهم يتجهون لمن يدفع
لجيوب الامريكيين اكثر اليوم هل هذا ما
يحتاج الناخب التركي وخصوصا اذا ما تحدثنا
عن توجهات باختصار
كما تعلمون السيد اردوغان ينافسوا في هذه
الانتخابات
في وجه
المعارضه الاقتصاديه التي في وجه المعارضه
التي تركز على الملف الاقتصادي
يرون ان العمله التركيه قد فقدت قدرا
كبيرا من قيمتها الامر الذي احد كان قد
نتج عن تبني نموذجا اقتصاديا سيئا باعتماد
على اسعار فائده منخفضه وهذا ما حدا
البنوك التركيه اللي اعتمادي النسب
المنخفضه لفتره من الزمن
وايضا اعتمد السيد اردوغان على السياسه
الاقتصاديه الارثوذكسيه او التقليديه التي
عكف على تبنيها
وتنفيذها لفتره طويله
ويرى بعض المسؤولين بان بان الاقتصاد في
الاونه الاخيره لم تنجح معه
تلك السياسه التي كانت موضعه جدل كبير
وكان يجدر العمل على اتخاذ السبل الذي
يمكن خلالها مكافحه التضخم والتحلي
بالشفافيه
هذه الامور مجتمعه قد زادت من وطاه
المشاكل التي التي يتعرضوا لها الرئيس
التركي بما في ذلك ايضا بوجود
مجموعات كبيره التي باتت ترفض تلك
السياسات
والفساد وسوء واستخدام الاموال العامه
والمناصب العامه
وعدم توافر
المواد الغذا الوجبات الغذائيه
بهذا القدر ونشكرك جزيل
الشكر التاسعه هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع
في سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
ارثوا والدته ابرز تحديات تشارلز الثالث
امام الشعب البريطاني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
استهداف روسيا خارج اوكرانيا هي
استراتيجيه بالحرب اعتمدتها كيف على مدى
الاشهر الماضيه اما الهدف الرئيسي
والمتكرر فتمثل بمقاطعه
الاقرب الى حدودها فباتت الاكثر تضررا
داخل الاراضي الروسيه من هذه الحرب
بالقرود اذا كما نتابع تقع عند هذه النقطه
جنوب غربي روسيا وتبعد نحو 50 كيلومترا عن
حدود اوكرانيا وتتشارك معها حدودا طولها
540 كيلومترا تعد اقرب مدينه روسيه الى
اقليم خارقيب بمسافه 71 كيلو مترا فقط
اهميه بالقرود تعود لجغرافيتها فهي تتقاطع
كما نتابع مع انهار كبيره اهمها دوناتس
وسفرسكي واوسكول وتميزها خطوط سكك حديديه
وطرق سريعه تربط موسكو بالمناطق الجنوبيه
والغربيه لروسيا وحتى ايضا اوكرانيا ما
يعني انها موقع مثالي في استراتيجيات
الامداد والتحرك الروسي في الداخل
الاوكراني ففيها طريق شبه جزيره القرمب
الخط السريع كما تتابعون خط سكه الحديد
موسكو
هي تشكل محطه لرجسيه روسيه هامه كذلك حيث
يتم تدريب الاحتياط الذي قد يتحرك باتجاه
خاركيف او ازيوم كما تتمثل الاهداف
الرئيسيه الاخرى بمخازن الوقود وذخيره
وخزانات ومصافي وخطوط البترول
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى موسكو معنا
المحلل العسكري سيد بابيلا مرحبا بكم معنا
في التاسعه هذا المساء اعداد كبيره من
الصواريخ والمصيرات الاوكرانيه تستهدف
بالقرود طوال السته اشهر الاخيره وحتى
اليوم لماذا هذا الاستهداف واين انضم
الدفاع الروسيه
كانت نقطه تجمع الروس للانطلاقي منها الى
مناطق اوكرانيا والى خاركيا وهذا الامر
كان خلال الفتره الممتده من فبراير الى
ابريل من العمل الماضي وبعد ذلك
تراجع الجنود الروسي جزئيا من منطقه خركيف
والان خطوط التحكم بصوره اساسيه
تقع على الحدود المشتركه بين الطرفين كل
من الطرفين
لا يسعيان للدفع باي اتجاه
ولا يوجد تصريح لاوكرانيا لتوجه الى
الحدود الروسيه
باعازل من حلفائها في الغرب وكذلك روسيا
لن تعود الى خركب هذا هذه مساله استنزاف
والامر وهذه المنطقه لديها اهميه
استراتيجيه بحكم موقعها لكن الاجراءات
الاساسيه تحدث في الفتره الحاليه باتجاه
الغرب وفي دومباس وزابروج
وعلى مقربه من المناطق البحريه وكل من
الطرفين على اتفاق بانه سوف سوف يعملان
على ابقاء هذا الخط الحدودي لكن سوف نرى
مناوشات بين فتره واخرى وهناك
مساء من قبل اوكرانيا لشن هجمات في العمق
الروسي بما في ذلك
توجيهي ضربات الى بعض البنى التحتيه
الاستراتيجيه المهمه وخطوط النقل والطاقه
الروسيه اوكرانيا بصوره اساسيه تقوم بالرد
بقوه على روسيا لكنها لا تعتزم ان تمضي
عبر الحدود للاسف انتهى الوقت من موسكو
هذا المحلل العسكري شكرا لك
اوكرانيا تحت ضغوط هائله على المدى القصير
من داعميها الغربيين بحسب نيوكس الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها يعتبرون الهجوم المضاد
اختبارا حاسما لمعرفه ما اذا كانت الاسلحه
والتدريب وذخيره التي ارسلها لكييف خلال
الاشهر الاخيره ستتم ترجمتها الى مكاسب
على ارض المعركه فاوكرانيا بحسب الصحيفه
تخاطر بتقليص الدعم الغربي لها ان كان
الهجوم المضاد اقل من التوقعات عقب
مليارات الاسلحه والتدريب التي حصلت عليها
وقد ترزح تحت ضغط قبول المفاوضات في حال
فشلها في تحقيق تطلعات الغرب وما زاد
المخاوف الغربيه تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اوليكسي ريزني كوفا ان شركاء
اوكرانيا يبالغون في تقدير توقع الهجوم
المضاد مضيفا ان هذه المبالغه تقلق
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا نشير بناكل هذه الاحصائيات
والمعلومات تغيرت مع دعم العسكري
اللامحدود لكييف بعد بدء الحرب والذي شمل
دبابات ومدفعيه وانظمه دفاع جوي والكثير
من الذخائر وكلها من المعسكر الغربي بينما
كان الجيش الاوكراني يعتمد على المعدات
الروسيه السابقا وهو ما استدعى تدريب
الالاف من الجنود الاوكرانيين لمده اشهر
على كيفيه استخدام الاسلحه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ضمن النشاطات المرافقه لتتويج الملك
تشارلز الثالث اقيمت مادبه غداء في انحاء
الشوارع
لتبادل التهاني واحتساء الشاي والكعك
ومنها
مقر رئاسه حيث استضاف رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك وزوجته اكاشتو مورتي
السيده الاولى الامريكيه جيل بايدن
ومتطوعين ولاجئين اوكرانيين ومجموعات
الشباب لتناول طعام الغداء بمناسبه
التتويج
[موسيقى]
اذا بهرجه واحتفالات صاخبه امتدت لساعات
امتزجت فيها العراقه والتقاليد القديمه
باللمسات الحديثه الحفل التتويجي
والتاريخي اول ملك بريطاني جديد منذ 70
عاما انتهى فيما المهرجانات الشعبيه
متواصله لكن هذا الصغط تطغى عليه تحديات
كبيره تقع على عاتق الملك تشارلز الثالث
اولها انه لا يحظى بشعبيه كبيره بين
البريطانيين مقارنه بوالدته ثنيها يتمثل
باطاله عمر العائله المالكه فوفق احدث
استطلاعات الراي دعم الملكيه سجل ادنى
مستوياته منذ اكثر من 30 عاما
55% فقط من البريطانيين يرون ان بقاء
النظام الملكي مهم لحد كبير بينما ايد نحو
27% الغاء النظام الملكي تماما ومن
التحديات الجاثمه امام تشارلز الثالث ضمان
عدم انهيار الكومنويل الذي يراسه وهو
اتحاد سياسي يضم 56 دوله حيث بدات دول
بالاتحاد مناقشه علاقتها بالتاج البريطاني
على مدار السنوات الماضيه والسعي لتحول
الى جمهوريات والانفصال عن نظام الملكي
مثلا جاميكا فالملك الجديد سيتوجب عليه
كذلك تحديث المملكه بما يتماشى مع العصر
الجديد وتحديد هويتها وعلاقتها باوروبا
خصوصا بعد خروجها من الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من المملكه المتحده نذهب الى الولايات
المتحده التقدم بالسن يعني اكتساب خبره
اكثر نقطه ارتكاز دفاع رئيسه بكيت جو
بايدن عن قراره الترشح لولايه ثانيه بعد
تجاوزه عتبه الثمانين عاما الترشح ثم
امكانيه الفوز يعني ان بايدن سيؤدي اليمين
دستوريه في عمر يناهز 82 عاما وسيكون اقرب
الى التسعينات بحلول نهايه فترته ثانيه
بايدن مدافعا عن قراره اكد انه يعرف اكثر
من الغالبيه العظمى من الناس وانه الاكثر
خبره من اي شخص سبق له الترشح للمنصب ويجد
نفسه فاعلا
ومشرفا وفق صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه
علما بانه استطلاعا للراي اجري الشهر
الماضي اظهر ان 70% من الامريكيين لا
يؤيدون ترشيح بايدن لولايه ثانيه مع
تاكيدهم ان عامل العمر المؤثر الاكبر
برايهم
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الايطالي ان بلاده لا
تزال غير راضي عن الاعتذارات التي قدمتها
باريس بعد ان اتهم وزير داخليتها روما
باساءه التعامل مع مساله تدفق المهاجرين
حيث شدد على ضروره ان تقدم الحكومه
الفرنسيه توضيحات دقيقه بخصوص موقفها تجاه
تصريحات وزير الداخليتها الذي قال في وقت
سابق ان رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا
ميلوني لم تتمكن من حل مشاكل الهجره التي
تم انتخابها على اساسها
في نهايه نشره المساء لم يبقى الا ان نذكر
بالعناوين
الدول العربيه قرارا باستئناف مشرفه وفدا
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعات
مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه جامعه الدول
العربيه تعيد دمشق الى مقعدها مع مطالب
محدده وقرار عوده العلاقات مع الاعضاء
السيادي فردي
استمرار للشبكات في الخرطوم ومساعدته
الانسانيه سعوديه للشعب السوداني بقيمه
100 مليون دولار
يحاول التقرب منهم تكنولوجيا
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه قلقه من الضغوط
والتوقعات الغربيه العاليه حول الهجوم
المضاف
اذا التاسع هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبرنا
بالتاكيد مستمره فبعد قليل 360 طاهر بركه
ساعه اخباريه مختلفه اهلا يا طاهر مساء
الخير اهلا نادين وفينا نقول الحمد لله
على السلامه رجعتي بسلام لاوقات الليل
معنا بعد ادائب الصبح كنت بصباح العربيه
نكسب كمان اشياء جديده وخبره فالحمد لله
بس بتصير احلى لما تكوني معنا بالليل اهلا
وسهلا فيك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات